now
e
okay
folks back to back classes there two
days in a row I don't think I've ever
done that the class before so first time
for everything right
so just a reminder that we are
officially a third of the way through
the class after today right the class is
well underway so things are going to get
faster quizzes are going to come
valuations are going to come to you so
part of the reason I kept nagging you in
those first few weeks it's like a moment
of Peace before the all heck hell breaks
loose I mean most of you didn't listen
so now it's too late so welcome to hell
right so today we're going to continue
our discussion of cash flows but let's
see where we were we're talking about
leases being treated as debt right how
accountants used to do it how they're
doing it now but reminder again it's not
just lease it's any kind of contractual
commitment because effectively you're
borrowing money when you have a
contractual
commitment so what I'd like to do today
actually is talk a little bit more about
some of the issues some of the other
issues in cash flows that we will run
into sometime today maybe we'll start to
talk about money losing companies
remember at least one person in each
group has to have a money losing company
right and one of the ways analysts deal
with money losing companies to try to
get over the problem is they will take
the money losing company and normalize
the income by averaging the income over
the last 5 years and for some money
losing companies that's going to work
for some it's not going to so here's my
question if that is the way you're
normalizing income is taking the average
income over the last five years giving
you a positive number okay under which
of the so what are you assuming when you
do that first are you assuming the loss
was unusual and that it's now going to
go away in effect you are right that
this is a one-time deal that there is
not some major structural problem that
the problems that cause the
loss have also shifted clearly I'm
implicitly assuming it the business has
not changed in fundamental ways yeah
you're assuming a mean reversion back
and finally the company has basically
not changed in terms of size why because
you take the average dollar earnings
over the last five years and your
revenues have doubled even though that
might be the average earnings that's not
going to capture you're making all those
assumptions but you're making them
implicitly and that's the thing I'm
going to reinforce over and over in this
class is when we do valuation we make
implicit assumptions
and that can get us into trouble because
sometimes those implicit assumptions can
be wrong and you're not even aware
because you're not making them explicit
so I'm going to encourage you whenever
you make or you use a number to Think
Through what are you assuming to use
that number we use a historical Equity
risk fre what is that implicit
assumption that you're making to get
away with
that
Sophia um the risk part will show up in
the discount rate so that will be that's
a second question I didn't ask you you
know when when we get to but if you use
the same average discount rate you did
over the last 5 years that's exactly
what you'll be
doing let's say you're valuing equity in
a young company right you project out
free cash flows Equity cash flows left
over debt payments and you discount
those free cash flows Equity back to
today at the cost of equity for the
company so if you have a company that
has you know negative free cash Lo
Equity estimate free cash Lo equity in
Year One year two year three and then it
turns positive and you discount them all
back so my question is really again
about implicit
assumptions when you take those cash
flows in the future you get through the
negative cash flows and use the positive
cash flows what do you implicitly
assuming about these young companies
with negative free Cas
equity and when you have a negative free
cash Equity what has to happen you got
to raise fresh capital from whom either
The Venture capitals of the public
market implicitly what are you assuming
that Capital markets will stay open and
accessible for you to do that is that a
safe assumption markets like the us we
used to think ah what's a big deal but
if you have years like 2008 or right
after theom bus where people would know
you can see that Capital markets can
sometimes shut down and in markets like
Argentina they shut down all the
time again it's an implicit assumption I
see people valuing young companies that
project the cash flows out negative cash
flows will return positive Nirvana will
show up as a big terminal value you
discount it all back say oh my God the
stock is worth $20 you buy the stock and
a year later the stock goes under and
you say what happened you miss it's
called truncation risk we're very bad at
dealing with truncation risk and
valuation it does it can't show up any
discount rate because it's not the kind
of risk discount so we're going to talk
more explicitly about what do you do
about failure risk and truncation risk
because in companies like young startups
you will overvalue the company if you
don't Factor those
in so follow that way because we're
going to talk I'll give you more
specific examples but today I want
to go back to where I left you yesterday
in terms of the notes we were talking
about capitalizing R&D so I want to talk
I want to step back and talk about what
exactly we're doing when we capitalize
leases the basic problem you with
accounting the way it used to be pre2 19
is because they treated lease expenses
of the operating Le expenses they
misstated operating income because it
was subtracting an operating expense
which was in fact a financial expense
that was the first problem the second is
because those lease commitments were not
treated as debt when you looked at the
balance sheet remember for The Gap you
saw 1.97 billion when you should have
seen 6 and a half billion so your income
statements get screwed up your balance
sheet gets screwed up the reason we
capitalize leases to fix problem so
let's see what we do when we capitalize
leases first you restate the operating
income by doing what by adding back the
lease expense saying I shouldn't have
subtracted out and subtracting the
depreciation will you get a higher
operating income much of the time yes
but some of the time you might get a
lower operating income you have a
company with leases that are
shrinking second you bring the leases as
debt into the balance sheet you get a
very different balance sheet because
when you bring the leases onto the
balance sheet as debt you also change
the assets out of the balance sheet the
balance sheet looks bigger in dollar
terms if you get a chance compare
Walmart's 2019 balance sheet which is
the first year in which leases were
treated as dead to their 2018 balance
sheet to see how much of a difference
that change in rules made but I think
you need to do it because without doing
it you get a very skewed vision of both
the profitability and The Leverage of a
company it'll also play out in almost
every ratio you compute and for the
moment many of those ratios I won't go
through in detail yeah but one of the
ratios you compute to look at how good a
company is in picking projects is a
return invested capital and with a gap
remember that number went from 12.9% to
99.3% you're looking to see whether your
company's in a good business and to
answer the question you do have to bring
your contractual commitments onto the
balance
sheet so any intutive question because
as I said for most of you accountants
are doing this already right I actually
know don't trust accountants so even
though accountants are doing it I
continue to do it on my own because I
did it you know I've been doing it for
30 years and I said well know they're
doing it let's see if they're doing it
right the one thing I have to noce
accounting as is their want is when they
wrote the rules to capitalize leases
also wrote sub
rules and Sub sub rules because they
like to write a lot of rules so one of
the things they did was actually
sensible they said if leases are
flexible you know what flexible let's
say you have a 10e lease but I allow you
to walk away from from your lease a year
in or two years out without paying any
money they said it's really not debt
because then you're not stuck with it
because the essence of a contractual
claim is if things are bad you can walk
you can't walk away from it so they
actually allow Escape hatches where if
you can get your leases to be flexible
they won't count it as that the only
problem is accountants write these rules
then what do companies do they look at
the rules and then they game the
system in India a whole set of compan
companies that had leases went back to
the Lort rewrote the lease contract so
that they could have the flexibility
then went to the account and said all
our debt is now flexible so you don't
have to count
leases one of the reasons I stay with my
Approach is I don't want to be subject
to that gaming but to show you how much
the gaming makes a difference there's
the account so every year when I look at
the balance sheets for companies 2025
2024 I add up all the debt that
accountants called lease debt so that's
the accounting estimate I then estimate
my own version because they still report
the contractual commitments like they
used to so I can take the present value
and I can compare the two numbers so if
you take Australia New Zealand and
Canada the accounting estimate of debt
of the companies is 8.4 really my
estimate is 13.6 so it's a higher number
and my estimate is 60 so their estimate
is 62% of mine I'm counting in Lisa's
debt that they're not in the
US I get it as about as close as it can
so us companies I am pretty close to
what the accountants are doing but you
look at much of the world just because
accountants tell you they're capturing
leases as debt doesn't mean that they
are so my suggestion is if you have a
company that's leased debt on the
balance sheet just check it out see if
it's in fact no and just staying on this
theme now we talked about contractual
commitments anybody valuing
Netflix no at least six or seven people
always end up with Netflix because it's
too late in the semester they haven't
picked a company it's 10:00 at night
you're watching Netflix oh my God I
haven't picked a company I'll pick
Netflix right so some of you will end up
with Netflix by desperation because you
haven't thought about a company Netflix
has lease commitments they
small but a lot of the stuff on Netflix
now is made for Netflix stuff but they
also have movies that other people make
for a long time they carry the Avengers
movies how did they get to carry the
Avengers why did Disney let them do it
what did Disney get in return
basically a contractual commitment is a
fiveyear I think $450 million same thing
with a signf shows right that they carry
the basically you pay the producing
company and you sign a five or a 10year
contract agreeing to pay 90 million a
year every year for the next 5 years do
you see where this is going right that's
looks a lot like a contractual
Commitment if you open up the Netflix
footnotes they'll have lease commitments
they still show that but they also what
are called content commitments
those are the commitments for these
shows that they have on that they have
to continue so if I'm Val Netflix I'm
going to treat the content commitments
like debt capitalize them and bring them
onto the balance sheet okay so let
leases be the starting point for the
discussion but think about other
contractual commitments as well any
questions on leases yes
sopia not exactly on leases but yeah but
leases were not C we're converting into
debt so basically but
[Music]
invest but then in this
case uh you would yesterday we talked
about how we should qualify as
Investments spending on let me draw
Contra with leases we're not converting
operating to Capital expenses we're
converting operating to financing
expenses right so basically all we're
doing is moving a line item from above
the operating income to below so the net
income is not going to be affected when
I capitalize leases right because it is
an expense when I capitalize R&D then
we're doing what you're saying we're
taking something right off the income
statement we're creating an asset we're
essentially making it a capital expense
so at the end of the R&D I mean let's
come back to this question because there
I think it's much more relevant as to
what exactly does that do to my cash
flows so let's move on to R&D let's
again start with the businesses where
R&D is a big deal and there should be no
surprises right you got drugs you got
software online retail I don't even know
what R&D they do but supposedly so I
just pull the numbers of the financial
statements so these are the the
businesses where R&D is a big deal and
right now it's being
expensed and these are the businesses
where there's an R&D so when a Coca-Cola
claims to do research my question is
what exactly are you researching I was
valuing Celsius yet yesterday I first
had to drink a can of Celsius before I
valued it cuz I kept hearing this is
amazing it'll make and I hated it but
but clearly people like it it's supposed
it at least in theory it's supposed to
give you all the soft beverage cake with
the energy and good health most of which
have turned out to be lies in the
aftermath but they have an R&D expense
and I said what exactly are they
researching but even if they're spending
money it's going to be a small amount
the payoff is not over 10 years you're
lucky it'll show up in the next year the
next two years so those are businesses
very little
R&D so with that in place let's think
about what it is about R&D that leads us
to question what accountants do go back
to the original definition of capital
expense it's an expense designed to
create benefits over many years by that
standard this is super capex right so
I'm going to start with the question
what is going through accounting heads
when you take a super capex and treat it
like an operating expense think like an
accountant for a moment snap out of it I
don't want you to stay there it can do
serious damage
right what is it that leads
accountants to treat
R&D as
a now about 12 years ago I was invited
to give a keynote speech at the aicpa
conference you know what the aicpa
conference is it's a conference of CPA
so thousands of CPAs usually in Vegas
sounds it's kind of ironic you gather
together as accountants and you have it
because Vegas is Big conference rooms so
they said will you come in and give a
keynote so I said let see why not so end
up in the Bellagio I get lost like 16
times getting this like that 27
restaurants 2,000 rooms I finally find
my way into this conference room with a
thousand accountants it's about as close
to hell as I can think of being know
and I gave a talk that made sure that I
would never get invited back again I
think the title of the talk was 10
things accountants do that I don't quite
understand and one of them happened to
be leases right that time I said what
are you guys doing with leases the
financing expense then I got to r&t and
I said you told me when I took my first
accounting class that if I have an
expense that creates benefits over many
years I should treat it as a capital
expenditure and here you are taking
R&D which is if it's if you're lucky
it's going and you treat it as an
operating expense why do you do it so
what do you think the most common
response was as to why accountants
expense are
they one is inertia right and let's so
basically it's and if you have got a CPA
you want inertia to hold because
otherwise your CPA deludes because
everything you've learned so that's what
else second they said R&D might not pay
off I said okay that's your dividing
line so built a factory in kazakistan
would you let me expense it Borat could
come in and burn it down any day right
in other words when I take a traditional
capex and there's a lot of uncertainty
you don't let me expense it why in the
case of R&D is uncertainty suddenly
rearing its ugly
head in fact that's the biggest reason
and the when that didn't work they came
up with the third
reason but you know so that was you know
they didn't even try that they said
we're just
being they want to be conservative they
they don't want to amortize it in fact
they said amortizing will spread this
out over time we're just being
conservative you see in what sense it's
conservative you take the R&D expense
you report lower income lower income is
more conservative than higher income and
being conservative is a good thing I
mean you got to think like an accountant
and therefore we expense it and I said
let stop right there when you expense
something what do you show on the
balance sheet the answer is absolutely
nothing so you know how this manifests
itself right if I expense something I
have lower income but because I don't
show it on the balance sheet my book
equity and the book Capital stay low so
when I compute the return equity for a
technology company guess what I get
Skyhigh numbers because the
denominator is missing your biggest
asset you've taken your biggest asset
off the books that's not conservative
that's the
opposite let me cut to the cheste there
no good reason for what accountants are
doing none so why aren't they fixing it
remember 1949 through 2019 70 years to
fix
leases by that standard maybe in the
year 2075 or 2089 or 2155 or 20 2,300
who knows they will get around to it I
won't be around to see that so I might
as well do something
today so here's how I'm going to
capitalize R&D and what I do with R&D
you can apply to any of the other
expenses we talked about acquiring new
customers customer brand name brand name
advertising so here's the first thing
I'm going to I'm going to estimate the
key word is estimate is I'm going to ask
you a question when you do R&D on
average through the on average in front
you're going to see why through done how
long does it take before you see a
commercial product let's pause right
there you r& how long does it take to
get a commercial product if you are a
pharmaceutical company what do you think
the answer consider that is going to be
a really long time right I mean Mona was
an exception it turned mRNA because Co
kind of kicked it and know without Co
Monna would still be working on it
wouldn't be commercial because you got
to pass through for good reasons right
you want to get drugs approved too
quickly might take 9 10 with
pharmaceutical companies I use 10 years
as an amortizable life cuz not only do
you have to come up with a new drug but
then you got to go through three stages
in the approval process takes a long if
you're a software company you're
probably not going to wait 10 years
you're probably looking at two or three
years you're making an estimate that's
my starting point let's say it's 10
years second stop I'm going to go
collect the R&D expenses every year for
the last 10 years or the last five years
if you have a fiveyear life I'm going to
collect the R&D expenses every year for
the last five years I know it's backward
looking but I'm because what I have to
do is to make sure that if I'm deciding
to capitalize that I've been doing this
for a while so this is not something I
can change just now I've got to go back
and do it as if I've been doing it all
the way through and you can see where
this is going right if I have a 5year
amortizable life and I have an R&D
expense from 5 years ago I'd have
written off 1/5 each year basically I am
amortizing an equal amount each year
because that's what accountants do with
capital expenses you're saying why
straight line why am I going to go look
for trouble with some of the year digits
depreciation all the I mean I have
enough troubles on my hand anyway so
keep it simple in terms of depreciation
so here's how it play out this is sap
sap is a German software company I gave
it a fiveyear life because in business
software takes a longer time for
software to pay off fiveyear life I
collected the R&D expense for the
current year 1.02 billion EUR and R&D
expenses each year for the last five
years let's go back to five years ago
five years ago they spent 744 M million
euros if I'd been capitalizing then I'd
have been writing off 1/5th eacher the
last 1 is being written off this year
and there's nothing left of it so I'm
tracking both how much I'm writing off
which is always 1 and how much is left
over R&D from 4 years ago 969 million
I'm writing off 1 there's 1th left over
R&D from 3 years ago I'm writing off 1
there's two fifths left over you get a
sense of why the number of this left
over is higher and higher as you get
closer and closer today there's more
left over if you add up the last column
you get 93 million what does that
capture it captures the amortization of
R&D that I'd have had on my income
statement this year if I'd been
capitalizing R&D all the way through if
you add up the second to last column you
come up at 2.9 billion you're saying
what the heck is that that will now show
up on my balance sheet as an asset for
lack of a better term let's call it
capital invested in R&D R&D Capital
asset 2.9 billion but then I have a
problem right my balance sheet doesn't
balance I have to raise either Equity or
debt so which one do you think I should
raise with R&D where did the money come
from for the
R&D so Fe it came from Equity investors
because it came out of income so my book
Equity will increase by 2.9 billion do
you see why this is going to play out
right when I do a return in equity now
my book value of equity will reflect the
additional 2.9 billion I'm trying to
bring your biggest asset on the books
and restate your income because if I
don't do that then you your earnings
can't be compared to the earnings of GM
of Ford which because have two sets of
rules right GM and Ford have a capex
accountants let them cap you know
depreciate over time I Microsoft I have
R&D I'm required to write it off this
here the p ratio of Microsoft cannot be
compared to the PE ratio for Ford
because I'm using two sets of rules to
come up with net
income so using the same process I did
for the Gap let me take you through what
will happen to all of your numbers if I
capitalize R&D First Step my earnings
which if I so this were these were the
earnings with the accounting treatment
of R&D R&D treat is an expense if I
capitalize R&D my earnings will go up so
as you go through each step ask you have
I worked at sap this look good for me so
you have higher earnings you're saying
this is good and you can see why right
because I've taken an R&D expense and
replaced it with an amortization that's
lower so your income goes up and you go
to the balance sheet
the book Equity that that um that sap
had was 3.76 eight billion euros but I
think it's understated because it
doesn't include the money they spent on
R&D so when I capitalize R&D my book
Equity increases to 6.78 billion I have
more book
Equity when I look at my capex my
traditional capex from the statement of
cash flows looks like a company's
reinvesting nothing 2 million when I
capitalize R&D that net capex increases
to 119 million I'm bringing in the
effective r gued to my capex my income
is higher so I want you to keep that my
income is higher my capex is
higher if I work through the free cash
for the firm you're going to say why did
we waste our time doing it because I get
exactly the same free cash for the firm
and that shouldn't surprise you do I
write a check out when I when I spend an
R I'm spending money right whether I
call it capex saying why did we waste
our time then on this entire process two
reasons one is even though my freak cash
FL to the firm is the same the way I get
there is different right I have higher
earnings and higher reinvestment and
that's going to be something I need to
know when I tell a story about sa sap so
when I tell you company's going to grow
I can point to the fact that they're
reinvesting 199 million and also when I
compute things like return on Capital
return and Equity my numbers are now
going to reflect what the company
actually has invested in I'm going to
get much more sensible looking returns
and equity and capital for technology
firms when I capitalize
ring so again if you think about what
accountants do and the effect
accountants the way they treat R&D are
understating the income for most
technology and pharmaceutical companies
that's the first effect they're also
understating the book equity and the
book Capital invested in these companies
because of what they're doing what we're
doing is to try to adjust for those so
we capitalize R&D not because it changes
the free cash of the firm last year but
because it's gives us a better sense of
how profitable the company is how good
its projects are and how much it's
already invested in the business
Sophia
yeah that income wouldn't add
anation
for& back to something it was not
deducted
from it wasn't but it was dedu Ed but it
was called a total if you think about
the total R&D expense right some of it
was amortization the rest is the so I am
still getting that deduction right I'm
actually adding back only that portion
right so what if I redo the entire
income statement I would have
amortization of 900 and something
million in the income statement that's
what I'm adding back right so you almost
have to act like you're redoing all of
the accounting and doing it
right so as I said this is not just
about
R&D technology firms pharmaceutical
firms R&D is the item if you're an oil
company is actually an item analogous to
R&D an expense that oil companies have
that accountants routinely expense when
I think they should be capitalizing
anybody know what that is for an oil
company what's the analogous item to
R&D
yes Charlie come on Claire you should be
able to help me out here
exploration cost right and right now
it's expensed and I've never understood
that explor so basically you're right
that's what it's called exploration cost
it's when you go Ahad and look for oil
and say no we add that all up it is the
equivalent so you should be doing with
exploration cost what you do with
r if you're uber and you're acquiring
customers and you're spending immense
amount of money on no promotionals to do
it same process you might might not have
a 10-year life you might have a
three-year life or a 2-year life but you
can see that this is a much broader
issue again I use leases in r& is
opening opening a door to kind of
rethinking how accounting does things
and say maybe we should do it
differently I'm not trying to redo
accounting I'm going to let them do
their thing in fact I prefer that they
don't step on my turf I actually prefer
the pre 20109 accounting where they
didn't try to capitalize leases because
here's what would terrifies me
at some right now they capitalized
leases they showed us that but they also
still leave the
footnote one of these days you know what
they're going to do right they said
we're already capitalizing it you don't
no longer need the footnote we're going
to take it away please don't do that
because I don't trust you guys but this
is why I worry about this becoming what
I want accountants to do traditional
accounting things I can fix their
problems as long as it's pretty
transparent as to or give me the
information to do the fix any questions
about the capitalizing of R&D the
intuition why we do it and how it plays
out
yes that's a that's a really good
question because the tax guy still lets
you I mean so if you're a tech company
would you rather expense R&D or
capitalize it from a tax
perspective yeah expense it so you know
what as a tech company should probably
continue to expense it when I do my
valuation then even though when I
capitalize r& expenses I'm still going
to compute taxes with the old way so the
way I compute free cash for the firm
allows the tax benefits to continue into
your free cash flow because it's still
going to be there
right let's move on so we've talked
about normalizing cleaning up updating
earnings we've talked about cleaning up
after accountants let's talk about
onetime unusual uncommon charges right
let's suppose you're valuing a firm
which is reporting a loss of a half a
billion but you look up the income
statement there says onetime
charge of a
billion remember you're using this
income to forecast the future last
year's income doesn't matter so if last
year they lost a half a billion but the
reason they lost a half a billion is
because of a one-time charge of a
billion in forecasting the future what
would you use as your base number a loss
of 500 million because that's what they
reported
or should you just remove the onetime
charge and say it's truly one time it's
gone I should be using plus 500 million
any
ideas in other words you're saying this
if it's truly one time but then here's
what I suggest you should check check
the history and if every five years you
see a one-time charge of a bilon you
should start to get a little suspicious
right this is what Creative Accounting
has allowed companies to do is often
take expenses and a normal operating
expenses lump them up and take it as a
restructuring charge a one-time charge
hoping you never look and most analysts
are too lazy to look they do the
adjusted abaton oh my God this looks
great and every year you have a onetime
charge of billion three billion five
billion let's assume you look at the the
history of the company you notice every
five years they take a one-time charge
of a billion How would you how would
your answer now change if you notice
that
and which would be it won't be lost
right because basically it'll be minus
500 but that was after the billion
dollars but in a normal year it's only
200 million not a billion right one5 of
it so you'll end up with a profit of 300
million not 500 million so if it's
something that is recurring then you can
normalize it and average it out one of
the nice things again of having access
to Capital IQ and I keep pushing you on
this if you haven't now used that
resource is you can download the last 10
years you can look at the line items you
can see line items would pop up only
once every five years it's not rocket
science and you're saying my job is to
not tell you what the income was last
year it's to provide a basis for future
forecast so items that repeatedly show
up then it's your job to kind of bring
them
in let's move on
to what should truly give you nightmares
much as I like to dump on accountants I
open up the income statement the balance
sheet statement of cash flows I'm
building off that I can clean up for
accounting inconsistencies but you know
what I can't clean up
for accounting
fraud after the fact it can always look
like I should have caught that end drawn
fraud but the reality is accounting
fraud will completely devastate an
evaluation
so I'm not suggesting you should do it
but there's actually an entire body of
accounting called forensic accounting
you know what forensic accounting tries
to do look for clues that you're
actually committing
fraud I'll give you a couple of very
simple ones in the net income statement
in the income statement you get a
measure of earnings it's called a cruel
income what does that mean you follow a
cruel rules you basically record
transactions as they happen you record
expenses related to the transactions and
you come up with net income it's an
acral income you go to the statement of
cash flows in that first section you
take the net income and you're just for
working capital change and you add back
depreciation you come up with a measure
called Cash
income and the two numbers will be very
different acrel income and cash income
and that's normal but if every year your
acral income is greater than your cash
income so let's say you do this for 20
years and your acral income consistently
runs ahead of your cash income that's a
red flag something is going on here
they're using working capital to look
more profitable than they should be it's
not definitive that they're committing
fraud but that's what forensic
accounting is looking for Clues and
financial statements for things that
might lead you to believe that something
is being done in this company that isn't
right you know what's going to make this
even easier to do this is very
mechanical right you're going through
financial statements and footnotes is AI
you let it loose on an income statement
say give me the likelihood that there's
fraud in you they can go through the
checklist check check check check 20
items they have 18 of the 20 it's going
to be something that you're going to see
more at your work is some kind of tool
that you can use to go through financial
statement say this company I should be
more cautious about using the numbers
because they don't quite fully add up so
I'll send you a couple of references on
Forensic accounting they're tedious to
read I mean incredibly difficult you
think accounting is boring you should
see forensic
accountants really breed to themselves
you know they're like actuaries they're
very you know if you have actuaries
don't take it personally but they're
very very number oriented people but
it's good to kind of think about clues
that you're going to look for in a
financial statement to see if there's
fraud which brings us to those of you
who are doing the money losing company
I'm going to ask a question and I expect
one fifth of the class to have their
hands up or one sth of the class who's
doing the money losing company in this
class
okay sopia's doing one who you doing
what company are you doing sorry what
what what is it DraftKings do you do a
lot of gambling on the weekends as well
too this was this an Impulse choice or
was I think it's a fun company to Value
you know but it's a money losing company
why is it losing
money sounds like a stupid question
answer right the expenses run ahead of
their income but that's why you start
the money losing company analys with and
here are the here could be the reasons
and you tell me after I've listed the
reasons which one you think applies it
could be that they had a one time or an
extraordinary charge you think that's
the reason with
DraftKings probably not right it could
be some macro Factor if you're a
cyclical company you could be losing
money because you're in a recession if
you're an oil company you could be
losing money because you have low low
oil prices you think that could be the
reason for
DraftKings is the NFL doing really badly
I mean after all no I don't think
there's a macro reason could it be that
it's a young company still working on
its business
model absolutely right it's a young
company it's got lots of potential but
there are states where you can't gamble
yet and it could potentially have
Revenue growth there it'll have
competition so but it's a young company
working its way through or it could be a
company which has structural problems a
company which has you know plant and
Equipment which is dated so it cost them
30% more than their competition to make
it DraftKings doesn't really have any so
it's a young company you're saying why
does it matter why I'm losing money
because the way you fix the problem will
be different depending on each of these
reasons now there was a time when boing
was a healthy
company that time is passed but there
was a
time but every 7eventh or 10th year
Boeing would report a loss why because
every seventh or 10 10th year they would
have a strike well for two months boing
would shut down and when you have a two
month shut down in boing it's a huge
deal because those lands if you go like
half a mile big and you shut them down
getting them restarted so when you shut
the company down we would create a
one-time charge of a billion a billion
and a half if you are valuing boying in
a year after a strike and you looked at
their financials there were money losing
companies it's the easiest problem to
fix because you can then smooth out like
we talked about and come up with a
normalized income and kind of move on so
if you have a money losing company where
the loss is coming from something that
happened last year that you think is is
now done the strike is over it won't
come back for another seven or 10 years
you can use that if you have a cyclical
company that's losing money because
there's a
recession solution is just as simple
right because as the economy comes back
your company's going to come back you
can try to forecast how the economy will
come back my advice is don't try that
because nobody's ever sure but you can
say you know Toyota as an auto company
makes 7% margins in a typical year in a
recession they've lost money but they're
going to revert back to the 7% once the
recession
ends and you can you're basically
assuming that it's entirely cyclical if
it's a young company you have a much
tougher task with
DraftKings you have to get a sense of
what will the company make as
margins once it gets through the growth
pain sounds like a mess messy question
it is we'll talk more about making the
Judgment but you have to pick a Target
margin it's not going to go to the
Target next year or two years from now
it's going to take a while so with young
companies you're going nursing the
company back to help and hoping it makes
it with companies with structural
problems you have the same issue but now
there's a morbid ring to the question
right you have a structural problem your
cost is 30% higher you might be able to
fix the structural problem and in your
valuation you can say once they do it
this is how much it's going to cost to
fix a problem this is what the margins
will look like again looking very much
like a young company but this is a more
mature or declining
company or you can say say look the
structural problems can't be fixed and
you'll have one of those dur valuations
where you get to year three year four
year five nothing really changes they
continue to lose money and the company
crashes and burns so as a general
General problem if you have the money
losing company stop and ask why is my
company losing money put into one of the
four buckets because it's going to frame
how to fix the problem
yes it's going to be tiny right do you
have the same problem the fact fact that
you're not losing money is is not if you
have a 0.1% margin you're making money
but that's not the basis it's not a
margin you can use for forecasting the
future right if you continue to make the
0.1% or the 1% margin so even if you've
just started to make money you still
have exactly the same problem that he
has with DraftKings right you got to
figure out what the margins will look
like once things settled down once you
got through the growth pins and that
problem Still Remains even the good news
is now that you've turned the Corner
you're less likely to
fail right because you don't have to
worry about external Capital as much now
that you so it's a it's it'll make me a
little more optimistic in valuing a
company but that the the task of
forecasting a margin Still
Remains so any questions on the earnings
part because we're now are going to turn
to taxes and to reinvestment
right so when we did tax rates for cost
of debt Sophia yeah
when they just arve to the market they
do they make their price very low is for
the dump prices to get the market share
would we assume this to be young company
thing or just a business choice right
that because you don't have to do that
did everybody sopia's question look at
every platform company I remember when I
first used Uber to get from New York
airport to New York City and it cost me
$16 and I said how did these guys make
money and the answer was they
weren't the driver was making like $5 an
hour the company was losing money why
did they do it because they wanted me to
be on the
platform it's a strategic Choice you're
putting scaling up and effectively
you're going to succeed in terms of
attracting people but if this is your
end game that you're going to continue
need to charge $16 what's going to
happen to you as a company you're going
to crash and burn right so if you're
Ving a company like that that's okay as
your starting point you will lose money
while you're building your platform but
you better have a plan on how you're
going to charge me three times as much
six years from now and the problem with
that is once you get people used to low
prices it's very difficult to fix your
model one of my pet peeves with VCS
encouraging companies to do this on
platform company after platform company
we just give the stuff away and then
once they're on you can charge a higher
price you've kind of train them with a
very bad model right so it's again the
variation of this is Netflix Netflix for
a while the way they attracted
subscribers was by dumping huge amounts
of content no entertainment company in
history had ever done what Netflix did
which is make 50 new shows a day and
hope to stick it's an expensive way of
doing things but it got a lot of
subscript
ERS because each one has a niche market
even the worst show in the world is
somebody who says I love that show it's
a terrible business model and for
Netflix that's always been my question
how do you step I mean the way I think
about Netflix in terms of stories is a
hamster on a wheel they're on this wheel
where they have to keep making content
to get new customers you get new
customers you got to make even more
content how do you stop this when your
customers are used when I turn on
Netflix I expect to see at least 20 new
shows
because that's what they've trained me
to do all of them are bad I kind of
expect that as well but that's the
business model it's very difficult to
alter business models and that's why
many of the the big platform companies
that went public in the last decade are
still
struggling with the with with the
money-making part of the business yes
that's that's a killer right that's what
you don't control is not only do you
have to be able to raise prices but you
if they if new companies keep getting
formed that keep giving away stuff for
free you're going to drag the entire
business model
down to essentially a lowest common
multiple every company will now be
scaled up lose a lot of money I mean
it's always been my pet PE with right
sharing as a business is there's no
stickiness in the business you know what
I mean by
stickiness I often take the Redeye
flight from San Diego to New York I get
on 9:00 at night I land at 5:15 in the
morning because I have to teach at 10:30
one of the few times I take U know right
sharing I land in New York airport and I
check the fair on Uber and then I check
the fair on left and every single time
guess which one I
pick the cheaper one I have zero loyalty
to either you look the drivers right
they can drive for Uber and lift zero
loyalty you cannot build a model without
stickiness and to me the the big test
for Uber is how do you build that
stickiness in do any of you have Uber
one right that's a way of building
stickiness right it's like Airline Ms
basically if you're an Uber one you're
going to take Uber over lift because you
get these added benefits it's a start
it's not going to be as easy to build
stickiness in this because you know you
know who takes Uber one I think you must
take an Uber to get to the classroom
from
upstairs no you take a lot of uber to
get Uber one right so basically the
biggest users will jump on the the
subscription the Uber one model but it's
there attempt to get stickiness no and I
think the fact that bill Amman is
investing in it suggests to me that he
thinks there stickiness in the model
because that's a big part of how he
invest but that becomes part of can you
actually raise price if you have no
stickiness it's going to be very
difficult to raise prices and have it
St yeah so think about your company if
it's a one of those platform companies
that's growing and losing money the test
you have is is there a way they can get
out of this box they've created for
themselves let's talk about taxes
remember we talked about tax rates when
we did cost of
debt remember what tax rate remember two
tax rates Marin and effective in the
case of cost of debt what do we say we
use to get the off tax cost to debt do
you remember what it
was try again marginal tax rate that's
good so marginal tax rate and tell me
why why do we use the marginal tax R
when we do after tax cost of
debt no don't use that reason because
that's like an accountant right I want
to be conser no we're not conservative
we want to do the right thing how do
interest expenses work they save you
taxes at the margin I want you to
remember that because there are people
out there use the effective tax rate to
get the after tax cost dead you might be
working with some of them I want you to
be able to explain to them even if the a
managing director why it's the wrong
thing to do it's a marginal tax rate
because it's at the margin now we're
going to come back to a tax rate
question but in a different context we
have operating income right with your
with all you're normalizing you come up
with operating income you've cleaned up
you have to multiply that operating
income by a one minus tax rate to come
up with after tax operating and the
question is Which tax rate should I use
and I'll give you some choices you can
use the effective tax rate that average
tax rate you can use a tax rate you
computed by taking cash taxes paid
dividing by operating income it's called
a cash tax rate you can use the marginal
tax rate of the country in which you're
Incorporated maybe a weighted average
marginal tax rate of all the countries
you Opera in what a nightmare but you
might decide to go that route or maybe
you think none of the above but you
better give me what you would use
instead or this would be nice if it were
true you can use any of the above as
long as you are consistent if that were
true what's the easiest tax rate to work
within
valuation this uses zero tax rate right
if all you have to do is be consistent
I'd always use a zero tax rate so
clearly it can't be F if it's e you
better come up with an alternative so
really the question is do you want to
use an effective tax rate or a marginal
tax rate what do you
think and tell me why why is it
different then from the from the cost of
debt
argument you're looking at the entire
operating income of the company right
you're taking the entire Opera income
and say what tax rate very different
question than the cost of debt question
so you can start at the effective tax
rate but now I want to stop and ask
about what should I do as I go through
time should I leave it now I gave you
the example of Apple having an effective
tax rate of
12% marginal tax rate 25% if I leave
that at 12% I'm going to get much higher
after tax orbit income much higher cash
flows and a much higher value for Apple
if I push it all the way to 25% I'm
going to get much lower cash flows much
lower value so we know what the effect
is of staying effect of staying
marginal but let me talk let's talk
about the dangers of both those limits
if I just go to the marginal tax rates
say it's safe it's a higher number I
want to be conservative what's going to
be the consequence with companies like
apple I'm going to undervalue the
company because I've not given them the
fact that they have a tax benefit
they'll pay less in
taxes so that suggest we should stay
with the effective tax let's play that
through let's say I leave the effective
tax rate at 12% and lose 12%
forever what's a danger in doing
that what do we say causes the effective
tax rate to be lower than the marginal
tax rate you can defer taxes you have a
really good tax lawyer right and if I
leave it at 12% forever what am I
assuming about tax
deferral that you can defer taxes not
just your one not just your two but
forever and if you believe that there's
a padded cell in a federal penitentiary
waiting for you cuz that would be fraud
right eventually deferred taxes catch up
with you it seems like there's no
solution right Marg tax rates give you
too low value effective tax is there a
way I can split the
difference can I start with the
effective tax
rate such a pain let's not go that route
you know that'll be there's an easier
fix right I start with 12% do I have to
stay at
12% remember there's year 1 year 2 year
three year four I'm going towards my
terminal value and if you feel that tax
deferral is temporary you can move the
effective tax rate from 12 to
25% so by the time you get to your 10
you're no longer deferring taxes you
don't have this forever
issue the Excel spreadsheet that I sent
you you know I sent you an Excel
spreadsheet right it's called fcff
Simple Ginsu there's a story behind why
it's called Ginsu and I landed in the US
in 1979 I turn on the TV in La talk
about culture shock I came from a city
in India which had TV 2 hours a day and
they made you watch farming
shows I turn first thing that comes on
is roller derby women knocking each
other off in the circle and I said
really this is on TV and then I stayed
up late and they had this Ginsu knife
commercial it's a 30- minute commercial
with a Japanese chef and here's the
commercial there know three knives and
if you you know call in the next 5
minutes we'll send you three knps and if
you watched all the way through 30
minutes by the time you were at done
they gave you a chance to buy enough
knives to terrorize an entire
neighborhood like 35 knives so basically
they keep throwing additional knives so
if you do this now seven knives nine
knives 11 knives this spreadsheet
started as a spreadsheet with three
worksheets and like the Ginsu knife it
kept adding worksheet wouldn't it be
nice if you could compute know
capitalize leases capitalize R&D so
these worksheets were things are added
on but in that worksheet if you take a
look the default is I ask you for an
effective tax rate and then I ask you
for a modin tax rate the effective tax
rate comes from last year's numbers it's
a fact the modin tax rate comes the
country in which you're Incorporated the
default in the spreadsheet is over time
I move your effective tax rate to your
marginal tax rate because I think that's
a sensible thing to do but then I give
you the rope to hang yourself I say look
do you want to change the default and if
you say yes I will leave it at 12% so
take a look at that option and maybe you
of a company that has a low effective
tax rate that you don't think it's
because of defur it's low because they
operate in parts of the world they get
80% of their revenues from Ireland they
get know 12% tax rate they kind of lock
that in I leave you that option
precisely for companies like those so
the answer here is if you have an
effective tax rate and you want to use
it to start the process I think you
should the 12% the 14% but I think it is
dangerous to assume that you can keep
that defective tax rate below the
marginal tax rate forever there will be
some of your companies where you're
going to see an effective tax rate that
exceeds the marginal tax rate why a
company pay more than the marginal tax
rate you know what kinds of companies
you're going to see this in first young
companies or more mature
companies it's going to be older
companies and you know why you're seeing
it is the tax deferral has caught up
with them they're now paying taxes for
income they don't feel sorry for that
right this is just you know the low
effective tax rate from 8 years ago
catching up when you forecast the future
you don't want to leave it at a 32% tax
rate so there you want to bring it down
very quickly to the marginal tax rate
but both cases can unfold any questions
on
taxes now as you're doing this this
semester could the world shift under you
especially if you're working with a
company with a lot of US
income yeah for the moment the marginal
tax rate in the US is 21% but who knows
what'll be by May of this year so be
adaptable be willing tojust it just an
input in so it's not a big deal but keep
an eye on how this comes through
yes tax rate orh the effective tax rate
is always based on acrel income so it's
always an acrel tax rate the reason you
want to make a cash tax rate it shows up
as part of working capital and
reinvestment so you'd be double counting
it if you used to cash tax rate so stay
with the tax income statement version of
of an effective tax rate right
let's talk about companies yes
sopia
ta tax referrals yeah but
either either the
progressive that's almost never going to
be the same for corporate taxes I'll
tell you why because in cor corporations
you hit the top level of income so
quickly that it's almost never because
with individuals you're right the reason
your effective tax rate can can can can
be lower than the marginal tax rate is
you start the first lab of income you
pay 25% so it builds up that's what with
companies you get through those lower
slabs so quickly that is almost never
the reason why your effective tax rate
is
lower let's talk about tax rates for
companies that have had a history of
losses when you lose money of course you
don't pay taxes that year right but what
are you allowed to do in much of the
world when you lose money even though
you don't pay
taxes yeah
you're allowed to carry that forward
it's called an N or a net operating loss
why would you carry it Forward because
when you first start to make money
you're allowed to take those NS and
offset your income so let's play a
little mechanical game let's say you're
valuing a company it has a billion
dollars in nool from previous years and
many of you young startups DraftKings
for instance will have a big n because
it's been losing money for a long time
right I'm going to project out income
for the next three years and I want you
to take this nool and show me how it'll
affect your after tax operating income
I've kept the numbers nice and round you
don't need a calculator you got a
billion dollar nool you're projecting
our taxes near one how much you going to
pay in
taxes zero so you're going to have a
zero tax rate near one zero tax rate in
year two but remember each year time you
use it the N is getting smaller so by
the time you get to the end of year two
the N is now gone in year three you're
going to jump to the marginal tax rate
this two is built into your spreadsheet
another Ginsu feature so if you have a
money losing company not only do I start
with your NL I keep track of your losses
I build up your nool and when you start
to make money I use that
nool to cover your taxes you don't have
to do anything it actually gets done but
basically it's a way of capturing the
tax benefits of having an no
y it be a gradual
process no change in the tax rate is
coming from a from a legis ative action
right it's not your company you talking
about changes in the marginal
tax but it probably doesn't make a
difference right you know the bigger
question is are you moving to the 25%
your terminal value if so if you go 18
21 20 the effect on value is so small
know that I think the spreadsheet has a
linear adjustment for the first five
years I leave the effective tax rate and
then I gradually move you towards it but
if you want to finesse it you can do
whatever makes you better
let's talk about reinvestment now when
we in valuation depreciation and capex
should be locked at the hip you know why
what do you get to
depreciate it's whatever your capex is
so I'm always troubled when I see
valuations where depreciation is a line
item and six lines below there's a capex
line item do you see why that's
dangerous you're an analyst late in the
evening you project out the depreciation
line at based on historical growth in
depreciation 2 hours later that's how
long it took you to go through the next
six line items you get to the capex line
item you take the capex and you let it
grow at 5% a year for because that's
what the growth is you let depreciation
grow at 10% a year capex grow at 5%
you're going to have a problem sooner
rather than later which is there'll be
not you know if your depreciation grows
that fast there'll be nothing left to
depreciate that's why in valuation I
think it's good to Twin the two numbers
together so in my free cash with the
firm calculation rather than add
depreciation and subtract capex which is
what I just subtract net capex the math
effect is exactly the same but by
netting the two I make sure that when
one changes the other changes as well
because the net capex measures what
you're reinvesting the only thing I
would add is when you look at you know
this net cap ex that assumption you're
making it has to be tied to the story
you're telling me about growth so if in
the in the revenues you're telling me
this big upbeat story of 50% growth for
the next 10 years when I look at your
net capex I expect numbers there that
reflect your growth rate you can't claim
that it's not your number your story
your number you pick a high growth rate
the net capex should reflect so twinning
net capex to growth I think keeps your
valuations
healthy and we've already said this
might as well reemphasize it when you
look at net
capex place you usually go is a
statement of cash flows capex and
depreciation but there you're getting an
accounting capex and accounting
appreciation and we've already talked
about the problem with that one
obviously is items like R&D which should
really be capex and we talked about how
to capitalize it but there's another
missing item in traditional capex that I
want to bring to the table when a
company wants to grow it can take lots
of projects right but it takes a long
time a lot of work so let's say you're
in a hurry to grow as a company what's a
shortcut that many companies use to grow
instead of taking a lot of
projects do an acquisition right I've
never understood why we separate
Acquisitions from other capex if the way
you grow is through Acquisitions it
should be treated like capex you're
saying but that'll make my cash flows
more negative
precisely because you're going to give
me a growth story about these
Acquisitions and if I want to buy into
your growth story that you're going to
acquire your way to growth I'm going to
give you the growth but I'm going to see
how much you're reinvesting to get that
growth through the
Acquisitions the bottom line is when you
compute the net capex for your company
using Finance principles rather than
accounting principles the number you're
going to get is going to be very very
different than just trusting the
accounting capex and depreciation so
I'll give you an example one of the
great companies of the
1990s was a company called
Cisco what did Cisco do make things that
I really didn't quite get but I needed
for the internet basically they were the
AR I mean I think described them as the
Nvidia of the internet age they made the
architecture
that made your
online business
grow and was one of the highest growth
companies in the 1990s it market cap
went from 4 billion in 1990 to 400
billion briefly the largest market cap
company for like 15 minutes in
1999 and it grew almost entirely through
Acquisitions they didn't do internal R&D
they basically bought promising
Technologies so in 1999 I took a look at
Cisco
and if you look at looked at Cisco then
they did Acquisitions and there are two
ways you can do an acquisition you can
pay cash in which case it's shows up in
the statement of cash flows or you can
pay with
shares and in 1999 if you paid with
shares it was called it was basically
called pooling which basically meant it
didn't show up in your balance sheet so
the purchase accounting are all cash
accounting I found them in the statement
of cash flows for the pooling I had to
go to the footnotes to find out what
they bought and how much they paid
collectively they spent $2.5 billion in
Acquisitions just in 1999 and this is a
onetime deal this is the way they grow
so I wanted to compute the free cash
flow to the firm for Cisco in
1999 so I started so to get how much the
total reinvestment was I started with
the statement of cash flows the
accounting definition and if I listen to
the accountants it looked like they were
reinvesting nothing 98 million net capex
but then I brought in the expense and I
capitalized it just like I did for sap
that adds another 1.1 billion and then
you bring in acquisitions by the time
you're done this is a company that is
investing immense amounts for the future
3.7 billion not the 98 million that you
got from looking at the income statement
so you can start with the financial
statements but when you think about how
much is this company reinvesting you
might have to look past the income
statements especially if they're using
shares to acquire companies to see what
a companies actually growing at it's
much more difficult to Value companies
that grow through Acquisitions precisely
for this reasons getting your hands on
how much they're spending each year to
get the growth becomes an exercise of
you you having to go through footnotes
and figure out what they
do remember the accounting definition of
working
capital you sh come on what's the
accounting definition of what
capital current assets minus current
liability right again I'm going to
screww up your accounting here that's
what accountants call working capital
that's not the working capital we use in
valuation the working capital we're
talking about in valuation is the
difference between non-cash current
assets and non debt current liabilities
let's take the easier half of that
equation
first when you look at the current
liability section of a balance sheet
somebody list out some of the items I
will see under current liabilities
accounts payable supplier credit but
keep going what else shows up under
current
liabilities shortterm debt short-term
portion of long-term debt right I mean
all those show up as current liabilities
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
strip the debt out of the current
liabilities and treat it as debt when I
do cost to Capital remember I said
whether you have short-term or long-term
debt the reason you don't count thatt as
part of working capital is because it
shows up as part of capital for your
cost of capital so I'm going to remove
now let's let's talk about why you
remove cash from current assets why does
inventory affect your cash flows if any
of you run a store and you have a lot of
inventory why does it make your cash
flows worse to have a lot of
inventory it's a wasting asset right
while something is Sting sitting on the
shelf it doesn't make any money for you
and if you sell items on credit and you
don't charge interest again you might
get paid but again it's a wasting ass
and in years ago cash was a wasting
asset why because if you're a company
even with large amounts of cash you had
to put in a bank at below Market rates
or no interest rate because you had no
choice so the really question the
question we face now is inventory is
still a wasting
asset receivables are still a wasting
asset but is Cash still a wasting asset
let's take apple $180 billion in cash
where is it sitting hopefully not as
currency in one infinity loop right
otherwise people will be breaking in
it'll be the next uh next show on how to
break into app so where is so when you
see a lot of cash big cash balances at
companies let's say us companies we'll
talk about non- us companies where is
that cash usually
invested they don't see you don't even
want to money market funds basically
will take a small slice so when you have
that much money you might as well go
directly to the US Treasury and you buy
tbls or commercial
paper and you make table rates or
commercial paper rates you're saying
that's terrible that's only
4.5% here's the question you have to ask
yourself now if you have a brokerage
account and there's cash in the
brokerage account can you invest that
cash into something
riskless and liquid yeah something like
TBL what will you make if you invest in
table
about
42% cash earns a low rate of return but
it earns a fair rate of return cash
invest in commercial paper T it's like a
zero Net Present Value investment see
where this is all going right cash today
is not a wasting asset it earns a fair
rate of return you know how much time is
wasted in valuation exercises on this
discussion of is it operating cash or
nonoperating cash I don't
care Walmart might need operating cash
but guess what while it's sitting around
if you invested in TBL and Commercial
paper it's not wasting cash so my
tendency with companies is to count none
of the cash because in today's day and
age there's no good reason why any
significant amount of cash should be
sitting as cash are there businesses
where I might include cash as part of
working capital yeah maybe if you're a
Colombian drug cartel and you say can
you come and in value me and you have
big stacks of currencies sitting around
I will count cash as part of working
capital but it' be so ter clarified of
getting the valuation wrong that I'll
give you whatever number you want in the
first place there aren't too many
Colombian drug cartels that I think
you're going to be valuing so if you're
looking at working capital make it
non-cash working capital non-cash
current assets minus non- dead curent
libraries now as you look at working
capital you know you can break it down
into all kinds of detail inventory
receivables payables my advice is
don't just take a consolidated number
because do you really want to be
forecasting days receivable for the next
10 years unless you have some special
skill with this why waste your time so
in terms of working capital detail for
the most part just do a Consolidated
number will it be volatile absolutely
especially the change number some years
you can have plus a billion minus a
billion the place to find working
capital changes is in the statement of
cash flows right below the net income in
the depreciation you see that try that
out for your company see what the change
in working capital and you could see it
kind of go all over the
place and there's there are a subset of
companies where working capital is going
to give you headaches these are
companies with negative working capital
how do you get Negative working capital
what's going to be true in these
companies their accounts payable and
supplyer credit are much more than the
receivables in
inventory I remember in the late
90s Amazon had negative working capital
it a great model for Amazon because
effectively they were using supplier
credit to grow and the reason they had
negative working capital is though when
they were online book retailer
Publishers wanted to be online an online
they would send their books to Amazon
Amazon get the books they would sell it
to you and I and collect the cash right
away but they wouldn't pay the publisher
for two months or 3 months effectively
they were using that float to keep
growing at one point I think that
negative working capital is like minus
20% of Revenue so basically they were
getting this huge capital inflow
and when you value a company you say
should I let that negative number grow
and there are some businesses where
working capital can actually end up
continuing to be negative because the
business model continues there in most
companies though as you scale
up that's going to get more and more
difficult to do Amazon's negative
working capital became a smaller and
smaller percentage of revenues as they
grew eventually it got to to a a low
positive number much lower than a
traditional retailer because they don't
have to Main maintain what I call show
inventory you know what show inventory
is if you walk into a bookstore in there
like Shakespeare or something across the
entire section of the book store where
there's nobody there that philosophy
section hundreds of books the little
Harry Potter section 15,000 people
around that section if you're a
bookstore though you're supposed to have
a philosophy section you're supposed to
be an intellectual place so you have to
have that section if you're Amazon you
know what you do you have thousands and
thousands of copies of Harry Potter and
if you want a philosophy book you tell
them they'll get somebody to write the
book for you and they'll mail it to you
there are so few people they don't have
to maintain books that they don't sell
which means their inventory can be much
slower as an online retailer so their
non-cash working capital remains lower
than a traditional retailer but as you
scale up it gets more difficult somebody
had a question that I kind of blew
through yes Sophia
that's be normal for any company that
works Bas of being their suppers for
example in if you refuse to accept a
card but the suppliers have to do it
there's an implicit cost which is I
think what get because you're saying why
don't I just use more and more supplier
credit because supplier credit is really
debt with an implied interest rate you
know what I mean by that right many
suppliers will give you a cash discount
if you pay immediately and if you take
60 days you lose that discount so on the
face of it it looks like a great deal to
you supply credit because you don't have
this interest bearing debt but you
replac interest bearing debt with this
implicit interest bearing debt and I
think we need to at least make it
explicit and say okay you want to use
supplier credit because it makes your
cash flows look better that's fine but
this is the interest rate you're paying
because you turn down that cash discount
from paying immediately so I think every
many companies have that option and
companies like Walmart one of the things
they've done is they've used their
Market power to actually make working
capital into this less less of a burd
because if you're a retail phone this is
a big deal right what I mean when when
Walmart came into being in 1988 89
whatever it was the conventional wisdom
in business was your working capital
should be your your non your current
assets should be twice current
liabilities people make up crap like
this and then people follow this crap
and Walmart said why if I keep my
current assets twice current liabilities
that's a huge working capital for me why
does it have to be two and no accountant
could give them a good answer other than
that's what it's always been and Walmart
said well we don't believe that so over
the LA if you look at the last 25 years
Walmart's business model is to keep make
the non-current cash current assets and
their current liabilities kind of level
off not as a source of capital but if
you make your working capital drain zero
as a big retailer that's like billions
of dollars of additional cash flows
and the way Walmart does it is you've go
to Walmart inventory is a big deal
there's a guy always going around
reading the code seeing what the
inventory is because you let inventory
buildt up that's a cash
trate they squeeze their
suppliers I know it sounds unethical but
they they you know and you're saying
what choice do I have 80% of my revenues
come from Walmart they say they'll pay
in 60 days and I have to take it or
leave it so they squeeze the suppliers
pushing out accounts payable the net
effect of all of this is their working
capital has now become a non-issue in
cash flows which effectively means that
they can push up their free cash flow to
the
firm now I'm at least going to set up
free cash flow according right
everything we've said so far is about a
pre- Deb cash flow but you can look at
free cash Equity the laziest way to do
that is just look at the dividends paid
on a stock dividends are what a company
actually pays out but the problem with
dividends is that dividends don't always
reflect what companies can afford to pay
out in my corporate finance class we
spent an entire sessions on why
companies might choose not to return
what they can in
dividends give me some reasons why might
managers choose to hold back cash that
they could have returned
yeah
something so one is you worry about the
fact that right now I have cash flows
but I could have bad years I'm a
cyclical company I've got to cover so
one is you know natural smoothing up
what
else one is I see an acquisition I want
that terrifies me but you're saying I
want to build up
cash anything else
yeah signaling stories kind both ways
right returning more cash can be a good
signal returning less cash can be a
signal you're right it could signal less
growth but it could also signal I get
less in cash flows yes
but I'm okay that's a cash return right
so if you're replacing dividends with
BuyBacks effectively I'm okay I'm
talking about companies that choose not
to pay dividends and hold on to the
cash that's that's different though
because that's cash you couldn't have
paid out in dividends anyway right
that's reinvestment you need so I'm
assuming that some reinvestment you need
for growth and after that reinvestment
there's still cash left over why you
choose not to return it could there be a
corporate governance angle to this who
gets to decide on how much pay the
manage of the company people around the
company right so when you don't like
what a US company is returning in the
form of dividends you can put pressure
on the company you might not call I can
will do it for you but basically
somebody puts pressure but if you're
have a family group company in India and
you're not paying out what you should in
dividends what chance do you have of
changing that there's a corporate
governance story Indian companies are
routin routinely under return cash
because corporate governance is
difficult to push through with these
companies so next session when we start
off given that those potential dividends
can be different we're going to talk
about ways of estimating those potential
divid moment was uh tax R yeah
why why would effective tax rates how
different from marginal before we said
that we use margin or is it for
different no no for the cost debt use
margin this cash flows cost always is
the margins right because you get the
interest tax savings at the margin apple
pays 12% effective tax rate but the the
interest expense on their debt is all in
the US and claimed against that taxable
income they say the
25% question relating to divid so in
smaller